ce qu'on attend surtout c'est une date
de réouverture c'est à dire une
visibilité tout le monde demande ça une
visibilité
ce ne sera pas le 20 janvier comme il
l'avait tant espéré les restaurateurs
vont devoir une fois de plus prendre
leur mal en patience avant de pouvoir
accueillir à nouveau leur clientèle pas
une surprise pour certains on était déjà
préparé avec les restaurants on sait qui
on est les premiers à souffrir des
saints ont fait que de l'emporter
et on a la charge et on faisait déjà
avant les fermetures
on a gardé nos clients et on a quelques
sociétés qui continuent de venir
apprendre à emporter pour nous aider
pour la vente à emporter comme maigre
lot de consolation pour ce restaurant de
montigny le bretonneux
ce mode de fonctionnement a été mis en
place à partir de décembre les plats
cuisinés de poissons notamment
on l'a fait comme je le disais tout à
l'heure en vente à emporter au mois de
décembre un petit peu un peu plus
fortement pour noël et jour de l'an
mais le total ça représente même pas 10%
du chiffre d'affaires habituel
le seul intérêt de la vente à emporter
pour nous c'est de rester présent dans
la tête de notre clientèle et puis sur
le plan commercial oscillent en plus du
chômage partiel qui couvrent 80 4% des
salaires l'état a mis progressivement
d'autres êtres en place depuis octobre
où on a dix mille euros par mois ça
arrive un peu tard quand même c'est
octobre novembre décembre alors que sur
toute l'année 2020 on a été fermé
pratiquement six mois la moitié de
l'année des restaurants qui vont bientôt
faire face à deux échéances importantes
les congés payés accumulés tout au long
de l'année ainsi que les remboursements
des prêts garantis par l'état